United Airlines Pilots taking steps to
avoid a strike today and Southwest
Pilots announcing the potential of one
this summer contract negotiations have
been ongoing with both Airlines for
years eight news now reporter Ryan
Matthey joins us live from breed
International and Ryan you're learning
that the pilot safe demands aren't met
this could be impacting the summer
through even winter travel is that
correct
Kirsten we all remember the Southwest
meltdown back from the winter time more
of those could potentially be on the
horizon now United airline pilots on the
other hand they were picketing Across
the Nation today including here at Harry
Reid International and if working
conditions don't improve for either
Airline it could mean a dent and travel
plans that extends through the winter
60. Las vegas-based United Airline
workers on Friday trying to get the
attention of those higher up our current
work rules are over 11 years old pilots
like Brian bunkers say pays part of the
problem but more so it's the scheduling
once a pilot clocks in he says they can
be Force extended for however long the
company needs them they can be
reassigned
to working on their days off so they
can't count on their kids dentist
appointment t-ball games anniversaries
birthdays we've been in contract
negotiations for well over three years
now
Captain Todd nikoi with the Southwest
Airlines Pilots Association tells me
they're losing a pilot a day to
competitors those leaving looking for
scheduling margins that are not so tight
it's just unsustainable because we're
short Pilots to begin with as those
negotiations continue potential strikes
Loom announced Thursday almost all
Southwest union members who were allowed
to vote authorized a strike that could
begin in late summer and go into the
winter holiday it is stressful while Las
Vegas travel agent Robert breidel cast
doubt that these strikes will come to
fruition he says it's not impossible
meaning potential impacts to passengers
especially as he says international
travel to the recently open borders of
Australia China and Japan are surging if
you have 30 or 35 percent of the total
flights cancel on us it's just going to
take us time and and most customers I
think will understand
important to note that neither Airline
is currently on strike neither of them
have even scheduled a strike now there
are a whole set of procedures in process
that Federal Law requires before a
strike can begin and that could take
months reporting live outside Reed
International Ryan Matthey 8 News Now